بلبله مستمره احدثتها وثائق البانتاجون
المسربه تفرعت عناوينها بين الاختراقات
والتجسس وخيانه الحلفاء لكن اضرارها لم
تتحدد بعد كما هويه المسرب الوثائق المئه
مشاهدينا اظهرت مدى عمق اختراق واشنطن
للاستخبارات الروسيه فقدمت تقييما لقوه
اله الحرب الروسيه والنتيجه جيش منهك
المواد المصنفه سريه للغايه اكد التقديم
موسكو مكافات ماليه لجنودها مقابل كل
دبابه غربيه يجري استهدافها او السيطره
عليها مع اقامه طبعا معسكرات تدريب للجنود
الروس حول نقاط ضعف دبابات النيتو الحاجه
للاسلحه على الجبهات وفق احدى الوثائق
دفعت مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه للاتصال سرا
بجهات تركيه في فبراير الماضي بمحاوله
للحصول على اسلحه ومعدات الجانب التركي
الجيش الاوكراني هو الاخر في حاله يرسلها
دفاعات جويه لن تصمد اكثر ومخزونات ذخيره
فارغه بحسب الوثائق وثائق البنتاجون افادت
كذلك بوجود قوات من حلف الناتو في
اوكرانيا بينهم فرنسيون وامريكيون
وبريطانيون تجسس واشنطن على الاعداء قابله
ادله بالوثائق على تجسسها على اقرب
الحلفاء مثل اسرائيل وكوريا الجنوبيه ما
ينذر بتعقيد العلاقات مع واشنطن فالحليل
في الاسيوي الكوري الجنوبيه نالت حصتها من
هذه الوثائق فكشفت هنا مشاهدينا مناقشات
خاصه بين كبار المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
الجنوبيين حول الضغط الامريكي عليها
للمساعده بامداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه رغم ان
سياسه سول تتعارض مع ذلك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات